hey they're true believers if you've
been fiending for more Marvel vs. Capcom
info have I got good news for you I'm
Tony and this is your super-powered
GameSpot news update don't let the name
fool you Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite
doesn't have an infinite amount of
characters but the latest trailer does
reveal eight new additions to the roster
Capcom is bringing chun-li Strider here
you and Chris Redfield to the party and
on the Marvel side we're getting Hulk
Thor Hawkeye Rocket Raccoon and Ultron
the Avengers villain is the big bad of
the story mode and he teams up with
megaman x's sigma to control both
universes the battle begins on ps4 Xbox
one and PC on Tuesday September 19th
don't forget to Like and subscribe to
keep up with all the new trailers and
characters from now until launch day
Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite comes in
standard deluxe and collector's editions
the deluxe edition includes the
character pass which will get you all
six post-launch fighters including the
aforementioned
Sigma the $200 collector's edition is
only available on ps4 and Xbox one but
that'll get you character dioramas of
Iron Man Captain Marvel Megaman X and
chun-li plus six Infinity stone replicas
pretty snazzy and for more Marvel love
right now you can always check out our
GameSpot universe Channel